[Music]
so last month the Encyclopedia
Brittanica announced that it is going
out of print
after 244 years which made me nostalgic
because I remember playing a game with
the colossal encyclopedia set in my
hometown library back when I was a kid
maybe 12 years old and I wondered if I
could update that game not just for
modern methods but for the modern me so
I tried I went to an online encyclopedia
Wikipedia and I entered the term earth
you can start anywhere this time I chose
earth and the first rule of the game is
pretty simple you just have to read the
article until you find something you
don't know and preferably something your
dad doesn't even know and in this case I
quickly found this the furthest point
from the center of the earth is not the
tip of Mount Everest like I might have
thought it's the tip of this mountain
mount Chimborazo in Ecuador the Earth
spins of course as it travels around the
Sun so the earth bulges a little bit
around the middle like some Earthlings
and even though mount Chimborazo isn't
the tallest mountain in the Andes it's
one degree away from the equator it's
riding that bulge and so the summit of
Chimborazo is the furthest point on
earth from the center of the earth and
it is really fun to say so I immediately
decided this is going to be the name of
the game or my new exclamation you can
use it at Ted Chimborazo right it's like
Eureka and bingo had a baby I didn't
know that that's pretty cool Chimborazo
so the next rule the game is also pretty
simple you just have to find another
term and look that up now in the old
days that meant getting out of volume
and browsing through it alphabetically
maybe get inside track that was fun
nowadays there are hundreds of links to
choose from I can go literally anywhere
in the world I think since I was already
in Ecuador I just decided to click on
the word tropical that took me to this
you know wet and warm band of the
tropics that encircles the earth now
that's the Tropic of Cancer on the north
and the Tropic of Capricorn in the South
that much I knew but I was surprised to
learn this
fact those are not cartographers lines
like you know latitude or the borders
between nations
they are astronomical phenomenon caused
by the earth tilt and they change they
move they go up they go down in fact for
years the Tropic of Cancer and the
Tropic of Capricorn have been steadily
drifting towards the equator at the rate
of about 15 metres per year and nobody
told me that I didn't know it Chimborazo
right so to keep the game going I just
have to find another term and look that
one up since I'm already in the tropics
I chose tropical rainforest famous for
its diversity human diversity there are
still dozens and dozens of uncontacted
tribes living on this planet they're all
over the globe but virtually all of them
live in tropical rainforests this is the
only place you can go nowadays and not
get you know friended right the link
that I clicked on here was well exotic
in the beginning and then absolutely
mysterious at the very end it mentioned
leopards and ring-tailed coati z-- and
poison dart frogs and boa constrictors
and then Coleoptera which turn out to be
beetles
now I clicked on this on purpose but if
I'd somehow gotten here by mistake it
does remind me you know for the band see
the Beatles for the cars in Volkswagen
Beetle but I am here for beetle beetles
this is the most successful order on the
planet by far something between 20 and
25% of all life-forms on the planet
including plants are beetles that means
the next time you were in the grocery
store take a look at the four people
ahead of you in line statistically one
of you is a beetle
and if it is you you are astonishingly
well adapted there our scavenger beetles
that pick the skin and flesh off of
bones and museums there are predator
beetles that attack other insects and
still look pretty cute to us there are
beetles that roll little balls of dung
great distances across the desert floor
to feed to their hatchlings this
reminded the ancient Egyptians of their
God Khepri who renews the ball of the
Sun every morning which is how that dung
rolling scarab became that sacred scarab
on the breastplate of the Pharaoh
Tutankhamen beetles I was reminded have
the most romantic flirtation in the
animal kingdom fireflies are not flies
fireflies are beetles fireflies are
Coleoptera and coleoptera communicate in
other ways as well like my next link the
chemical language of pheromones
now the pheromone page took me to a
video of a sea urchin having sex yeah
and the link to aphrodisiac now that's
something that increases sexual desire
possibly chocolate there is a compound
in chocolate called phenylethylamine
that might be an aphrodisiac but as the
article mentions because of enzyme
breakdown it's unlikely that
phenylethylamine will reach your brain
if taken orally so those of you who only
eat your chocolate you might have to
experiment and the link I click on here
sympathetic magic mostly because I
understand what both of those words mean
but not when they're together like that
I do like sympathy I do like magic so
when I click on sympathetic magic I get
sympathetic magic and voodoo dolls this
is the boy in me getting lucky again
right sympathetic magic is imitation if
you imitate something maybe you can have
an effect on it that's the idea behind
Buddha dolls and possibly also cave
paintings the link to cave paintings
takes me to some of the oldest art known
to humankind I would love to see Google
Maps inside some of these caves right
we've got tens of thousand years old
artwork common themes around the globe
include large wild animals and tracings
of human hands usually the left hand we
have been a dominantly right-handed
tribe for millennia so even though I
don't know why a Paleolithic person
would trace his hand or blow pigment on
it from a tube I can easily picture how
he did it and I really don't think it's
that different from our own little
dominant hand avatar right there that
I'm gonna use now to click on the term
for hand go to the page for hand where I
found the most fun and possibly
embarrassing bit of trivia I found in a
long time it's simply this the back of
the hand is formerly called the a piston
R now that's embarrassing because up
until now every time I've said I know it
like the back of my hand I've really
been saying I'm totally familiar with
that
I just don't know it's freaking name
right
and the link i clicked on here well
lemurs monkeys and chimpanzees have the
little a piston R I click on chimpanzee
and I get our closest genetic relative
Pan troglodytes the name we give him
means cave dweller he doesn't he lives
in rainforests and savannas it's just
that we're always thinking of this guy
is lagging behind us you know
evolutionarily or somehow uncannily
creeping up on us and in some cases he
gets places before us like my next link
the almost irresistible link ham the
Astro chimp I click on him I really
thought he was gonna bring me full
circle twice in fact he's born in
Cameroon which is smack in the middle of
my tropics map and more specifically his
skeleton wound up in the Smithsonian
Museum getting picked clean by beetles
in between those two landmarks and hams
life he flew into space he experienced
weightlessness and re-entry months
before the first human being to do it
Soviet cosmonaut Yuri Gagarin when I
click on you to go Gardens page I get
this guy who was surprisingly short in
stature huge and heroism top estimates
soviet estimates put this guy at 1.65
meters that is you know less than five
and a half feet tall max possibly
because he was malnourished as a child
Germans occupied Russia a Nazi officer
took over the Gagarin household and he
and his family built and lived in a mud
hut years later the boy from that
cramped mud hut would grow up to be the
man in that cramped capsule on the tip
of a rocket who volunteered to be
launched into outer space the first one
of any of us to really physically leave
this planet and he didn't just leave it
he circled it once 50 years later as a
tribute the International Space Station
which is still up there tonight synced
its orbit with Gagarin x' orbit at the
exact same time of day and filmed it so
you can go online and you can watch over
100 minutes of what must have been an
absolutely mesmerizing ride possibly a
lonely one the first person
ever see such a thing and then when
you've had your fill of that you can
click on one more link you can come back
to earth you return to where you started
you can finish your game you just need
to find one more fact that you didn't
know and for me I quickly landed on this
one
the earth has a tolerance of about point
17 percent from the reference spheroid
which is less than the point 22 percent
allowed in billiard balls this is the
kind of fact I would have loved as a boy
I found it myself it's got some math
that I can do I'm pretty sure my dad
doesn't know it right what this means is
that if you could shrink the earth to
the size of a billiard ball right if you
could take planet Earth with all its
mountaintops and caves and rainforests
astronauts and uncontacted tribes and
chimpanzees voodoo dolls fireflies
chocolate sea creatures making love and
the deep blue sea you just shrink that
to the size of a billiard ball it would
be as smooth as a billiard ball
presumably a billiard ball with a slight
bulge around the middle that's pretty
cool
I didn't know that Chimborazo thank you
[Applause]